He is the world's most famous cyclist
dominating his sport like no one before or
since yet.
His reputation has four ever been
tarnished by a scandal that tor the very
fabric of professional cycling,
pitting the sports elite
against one another.
The doping scandal,
however,
was just one in a series of mounds in
like obstacles that have confronted Lance
Armstrong.
This story of how he has overcome
them is one of perseverance,
tenacity,
and self belief.
And in this week's bland graphics,
we explore the tumultuous
life of Lance Armstrong
loans.
Edward Armstrong was born
as Lance Gunderson in Texas
on September the 18th 1971
his mother,
Linda,
was just 17 years old in
a high school dropout.
While his biological father at he
Gunderson was a route or manager for the
Dallas Morning News,
the marriage was an unhappy one with
Eddie at proving to be abusive and
neglectful.
They divorced when lance
was only two years old.
Before long lens up,
she had remarried and Lance,
his step father was a traveling
salesman named Terry Armstrong.
Armstrong was a stern,
distant man who never really bonded
with lungs during his formative years.
Terry's job kept him Oh,
away from home a lot,
and when he was home,
he proved to be a harsh disciplinary and
who would beat lance with a paddle for
any sort of incursion?
Not surprisingly,
the y looked forward to his stepfather's
work trips when it was just him and his
mother at home.
As the years progressed,
the family's finances improved since
they moved to better neighborhoods.
They ended up in Richardson where Linda
signed up young lance for swimming
lessons.
She also bought him a bicycle.
Young Lance was an active,
inquisitive.
Charles the often got into fights with
one scuff were getting kicked off the
school bus after which he
rode his bicycle to school.
Yeah,
I love of competitive sports though.
He never really clicked with football,
which was the dominant sport in Texas.
Instead,
he became passionate about
her running and swimming.
Lance has an abundance of energy.
His favorite TV show
was the $6 million man,
and he loved nothing better than to run
around the neighborhoods pretending to
be UV bionic man as he chunk did.
The words of the show's theme song better,
stronger,
faster from Richardson.
The Armstrongs move to Plano,
Texas,
where Linda Linda's new job as
a telecommunications company.
Secretary enabled them
to buy their first house.
It was here that they lived through
the bulk of Lance's schooling.
He attended the Armstrong middle school,
Williams hi and Plano East.
Hi.
Linda bought her son his first serious
bike when he was seven years old.
There was a Schwinn Mag
scrambler BMX racing bike,
the bike along with a helmet and safety
gear costs three times what Linda was
sleeping dispense,
but she saw the value in her son
involved in an outdoor sport.
Longs wrote his scrambler Antony was 13
when his mother bought him mercy I road
bike with his competitive career began
just 12 years old when he can beat it in
the Plano swim club champs.
He saw some success,
but a year later he saw a poster for a
triathlon and decided to switch to the
three discipline event is first.
Triathlon was the [inaudible] kids,
which he won pretty handily with.
His stepfather are often
absent from the home loans.
Lacks a strong male role model.
During his formative years.
That role was filled in his early teens
by Chris McCardy has Plano swimming,
coach McCarthy trained Armstrong right
through middle school and high school and
encouraged him to compete on a national
level and even to set his sights on the
Olympics and other man who
took an interest in the
teenage lance was the owner
of a local bicycle shop and
his name was Jim Height.
He gave the Armstrongs discounts on
equipment since lawns managed to answer
money writing for the events
that were sponsored by height.
When Lance was 14 he
competed and won his first.
Did you ask Lon consisting of swimming
and running the prize was a $100 pair of
avo running shoes.
However,
when the shoe's arrived in the mail,
they did not fit.
The sales rep who came to the Armstrong
home with a replacement paths,
got Eder,
ended up taking lance under his
wing and taking him do work outs and
competitions that took lance do
the Cooper Institute in Dallas.
When the boy was 16 the researchers
that tested his vo two Max,
which came out at 79.5% it was the
highest that they had ever seen.
This men's of alarms had an incredible
ability to make use of every breath of
oxygen that came into his body.
The testing also showed that he had the
highest lactic acid threshold that they
had ever come across
through his formative years.
Lance had a knack for getting
himself into quite a bit of trouble.
The and his mates would sneak into the
neighbor's house and steal beer from the
fridge.
On one occasion,
he and another boy glued the mailbox
as a man who they had argued with.
The police eventually came
calling when he stolen.
Armstrong street sign isn't ornaments
for his room when he was 16 however,
his mother told him that she was
planning on leaving his stepfather.
She,
Aj salons.
Do you stop getting into trouble that
she wouldn't be able to handle the stress
that it would bring to hop?
Moms responded to channeling all of
his energy into a sporting events.
Molson Linda now spent most weekends
together traveling to 10 k running events
and triathlons that he
competed in during the week.
Mom spent many hours going on long
rides with his cycling buddies.
Lindsey helped her son.
Do you see callus sponsors who would
supply such things as she is and Jesse's
every single sponsor received a
handwritten letter of thanks from Lance.
So there are four competitive
cycling categories.
All writers start out a cat for freelance.
This meant Tuesday nights criteria
and rides at the local bike march.
It wasn't long before he moved up to cat
three where he found himself training
with a couple of cat one guys when he
was 16 lance who's writing is messy,
a racing bike along the Dallas country
side when he was apparently run off the
road by a truck driver,
a furious lance curse at
the driver from the asphalt.
This caused the man to see red and the
stocks his truck and got out in a rage
launch,
jumped to his feet and took off.
But the man trashed his
bike before we left.
Lawrence managed to record
it's number place and uh,
proceeded to sue this man and when she
used the money to buy his son and you
Randy bike with racing wheels,
noncitizen you bike.
They didn't last long.
Not long after receiving his,
he was hit by an SUV while
running a yellow light.
He was thrown over the handlebars
and onto the hood of the SUV.
He was lucky to get away alive,
especially since he
wasn't wearing a helmet,
who turns up at the hospital
with a twisted foot,
some scrapes,
and a concussion with his foot laced
with stitches and the heavy brace lawns.
His doctor told him to do
nothing for the next three weeks,
but there was just one problem.
He had a triathlon race in six days.
The doctor simply told
him to forget about it.
Instead,
he got rid of the brace on the second day,
cut out the stitches himself with a
nail clipper and turns up Hamas starting
line.
That Saturday he led the swim and the
ride eventually coming in third when he
heard about it,
the doctor who had treated him,
he could hardly believe that by the
time of his final year in high school in
1989 launched was a national
level citing can pastor.
He had qualifying to train with the
junior national team at Colorado and
preparation for the world
junior championships.
Throughout his high school years,
Lance had missed a lot of school due to
is traveling around the countryside to
compete.
The school or however had viewed the
absences as being on par with playing
hooky.
They told him that he did not have leave
to go to Colorado or indeed to follow
on to Moscow to compete in
the world championships.
The facts of that cycling wasn't even
recognized as a sports by Texas high
schools at the time.
Certainly factored into their decision
making more was to come though despite is
working overtime to meet the requirements
or meeting was called where lance and
his mother were sold that he would not
be able to graduate with his class that
year.
They didn't care that he was an emerging
elite athletes with an unprecedented
opportunity to advance his career.
So then once he was simply a slacker,
Linda soon got her son into a private
school that would let him graduate the
teachers of the new school
bending Oaks Academy.
We're happy to work around
lancers schedule to help
him complete his schooling.
Armstrong's fierce competitiveness
brought into the attention of the coach of
the u s national cycling team,
Chris Carmichael,
Carmichael,
they didn't knows it.
He was so aggressive that either had tear
the field apart and the when or apple,
everyone after him.
So they blew by him at the ends.
Lawns qualified for and competed in the
junior world champs in Moscow in 1989
this was to prove to be his breakout,
yet he got more attention than others
because of his aggressive racing style and
he broke away from the main group in the
first lab arising in the front Peloton
and was right up there
until the final thrust.
Wow.
Stronger writers pushed ahead of him,
his performance and Moscow in Mark's
Armstrong as the most exciting new cyclist
on the world stage,
he showed himself to be an aggressive
competitor with the ability to focus like
a laser beam on achieving his goals.
He was supremely confidence,
which was easy to redesign arrogance.
He also had no interest in
writing as a part of a team.
He did the ones anything due to attract
him from his desire to cross the finish
line.
First,
it was in 1992 that Armstrong competed
at his first Olympics in Barcelona.
He loves you,
recall the t road and miserably as an
inexperienced hothead and to finish a
disappointing 14 from the road race.
There's performance.
However,
it wasn't enough to bring
him to the attention of the
director of a professional
sports team,
but we're sponsored by motor roller after
the games lawns with signed on to the
team,
which officially made him
a professional athlete.
I'm just the major road,
the banner long.
It's traveled to Europe in order to
compete in a series of road races as fast
race was and sounds sebasty in
Spain and t came in dead last.
The crowd jeered at him when he crossed
the line 30 minutes after the Winter
Armstrong with deflated after this race
and he considered flying back to the
United States.
But it's coach convinced him to stay
and prove himself and prove to his
teammates that he was no quitter and say,
well,
lawn stayed on from race to race.
He got better and he came in second the
Zurich championships finally telling
himself that he was capable of doing this.
One of Lance,
his biggest challenges with Motorola was
learning to work as part of a cycling
team.
He would quickly get frustrated with the
other riders in his Palatan yelling at
them to pull or get out of the way if
as it is with trying to frustrate him on
purpose,
encouraging him to take the lead and wear
himself out early after only 12 months
as a professional cyclist,
Landis had already earned the nickname
the king at the 1993 UCI track cycling
world championship and also the Norway,
the motor roller team decided that he
was ready to take the title and as they
would work with him to win the race
rather than rushing to the lead,
he stayed in the Peloton until the
second to last lap because he had been
instructed dude.
Then he attacked to take the lead and
stay that he crossed the line well ahead
of the competition and the bounds of the
crowd blew kisses and seeing what was
to become his trademark.
He pointed to the Sky Armstrong.
He was now the world champion,
this to truly be the vest.
He knew that he had to win the Tour de
France in 1995 he won a stage of the
world's greatest grace,
dedicating the win to a teammate
who had died during a crash.
In that very race in August of 1996
he signed a two year contract with the
coffee as cycling team
France
in 1996 salons notice that his
right testicle was becoming swollen.
This was followed by a dull
ache and then a lack of energy.
This is the thing that it is performance.
At the 96 Olympics,
Cindy had a disappointing
finish and his memoirs.
He recalled that he felt like he was
dragging a manhole cover during the road
race in October.
After returning from the Olympics,
Armstrong was diagnosed
with testicular cancer.
Yeah,
put off seeing a doctor,
but when he began coughing up a blood,
he knew that he had to act the news.
It rocked Armstrong as
well as the support team.
He was 25 an elite athlete and had stage
three testicular cancer that had spread
to his brain,
his lungs,
and his abdomen.
His chances of survival were estimated
to be below 50% and it looked pretty
likely that he would never race again.
Despite recently signing a two point
$5 million contract with [inaudible],
his team's liars decided that they would
not provide insurance coverage during
his treatments as the condition had not
been advised at the time of the signing
of the contract.
They want to sponsors,
however,
who did not abandon Armstrong
during his time of need.
Oakley even offered for him to be
covered under that health plan.
Armstrong took on the cancer challenge
with these same fierce determination that
had made him a well champion.
He underwent a program of
intense chemotherapy treatments.
He sought our sentence,
began treatment with a very caustic
chemo cocktail known as v I.
P which was less damaging on the
lungs than conventional treatments.
This choice,
it probably saved his cycling career
throughout his chemo treatments.
Armstrong competed sporadically.
Understandably,
he did not do well,
but he was keeping himself in the game.
The final chemo treatments it took
place on December the 13th 1996 and in
February of 1997 his doctors were able
to confirm that his cancer was in full
remission
on the stronger sounds
like competitive cycling.
At the beginning of 1998
his contracts with coffee,
this had been canceled in 1997 and he
had signed on with the US Postal Service
something team.
He moved to Europe with the team
to train for the tour to France.
Armstrong was now recognized as the
poster child for being a cancer survivor.
He received many awards and many titles
around 1998 he built successes one upon
another and the steadily improved.
Displacing that.
Yeah.
He also married his fiance,
Kristin Richard.
The marriage would last five years
and it would produce three children.
I'm the strong one.
His First Tour de France in 1999 he won
four stages and had learned to work well
with his teammates.
He finished the race.
It's seven minutes and 37 seconds ahead
of the second place finisher in a post
when interview.
He proclaims if you get a second chance
at life for something go all the way in
2000 and Armstrong came back to
France to 10 mins to defend his title.
The race turned down to be a battle
between him and [inaudible] Oreck who has
competed the previous.
Yeah.
This rivalry was to
continue for the next five.
Yes.
Armstrong cross the finish line.
Six minutes ahead of all Rick
to become a two time champion.
Armstrong dominated the cycling world in
the early 2000 years consecutive run of
Tour de France victories stretched on
to an unprecedented seven in a row from
1999 to 2005 following his July 24th,
2005 when he announced his
retirement from Connecticut
cycling
in the way you his stunning
1999 Tour de France victory.
There were allegations that Armstrong
must've been involved in either drug
taking or blood doping.
In early 2000 under the auspices
of the Nike Corporation,
He created a documentary
style advertisement entitled
body in order to answer
the detractors.
The film focused on his steely will to
win and showed footage of him undergoing
drug tests.
The voiceover narration,
it was done by Armstrong himself.
At one point he says,
everybody wants to know what I'm on.
What am I on?
I'm on my bike busting
my ass six hours a day.
What you wanted.
When results came through that he had
tested positive for a minute amount of
corticosteroid.
After the 99 Tour de France,
many people doubled down
on their accusations,
but the amounts in his body was seen.
My knew that they were not
enough to fail the test.
Since that one little blip,
he has never failed a drug test
that has however been quite a lot of
circumstantial evidence and 2004 a book
was published called La Confidential,
which claims at the time strong had
been using performance enhancing drugs.
They've quoted from Steve Swartz,
former motor roller team mate.
He claims that all the team members
were using as far back as 1995 when
allegations made in the
book were reprinted in the
British newspaper The Sunday
Times.
Armstrong sued them leading to
an out of court settlements.
In June of 2012 the U s antidoping agency
brought allegations against Armstrong
of running a huge doping ring among
his teammates cheering his competitive
career.
They weren't armed with testimony
from a number of former teammates.
Their goal was to have him banned from
any sport that followed the world,
Anti Doping Code Lance.
He did not appeal the band.
Armstrong continued to vehemently denied
the allegations of doping until 2013
then in a bombshell
interview with Oprah Winfrey.
He admitted that he had used performance
enhancing drugs for all of his tour de
France wins.
He claimed to have used a referee,
poet in and human growth hormone
and to have engaged in blood doping.
The reaction,
it was one of outrage parties
began lining up to sue Armstrong,
including teammates that he had called
Liars and parties that he had one libel
suits against.
The US Justice Department sued them for
millions of dollars that the US Postal
Service it's spent on
sponsorship to weld cycling,
Governing Body,
a few day lifetime ban to Armstrong.
He's still competes and amateur events.
However,
today he owns a coffee shop in Austin,
Texas and they bike shop
called mellow Johnny's.
Though he won't never shake the
reputation as the world's greatest cycling
cheat.
He has built a life for himself that
allows him to indulge his cycling passion
and his competitive nature
as an amateur athlete.
Following his successful
cancer treatments,
Armstrong started the
Lance Armstrong Foundation.
It began with a fundraising race.
Do you raise money for cancer research?
One of the most successful initiatives
over the foundation was the production in
2004 of a silicon bands in printed
with the words live strong.
Over 80 million of these bracelets
have been sold worldwide,
so I really hope you enjoyed that episode.
All biographics.
If you did this,
a couple of things you could do right now.
One is hit that like button below.
Also,
if you want more stuff like this,
we put out brand new videos
every Monday and every Thursday,
so hit that subscribe button below and
subscribe button doesn't do what it used
to on Youtube.
If you actually want to get a
notification about these videos,
please do hit that bell button next to
the subscribe button and that'll send you
a notification every time,
every Monday and Thursday
when we put out a new video.
Also,
if you want to watch
something else right now,
stuff from the archive
over there on the rise,
and as always,
thank you for watching.